bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler d'une
femme aux tris proto féministes du début
du xviie siècle
mais comme c'était une femme elle n'est
pas restée dans les mémoires malgré ses
efforts pour changer tout ça quelle
indignité
emilia bassano est née le 27 janvier
1569 à londres ses parents sont pas
tristes bassano musiciens de cour de la
reine elizabeth est originaire de venise
et margret johnson peut-être que sa
famille était juive ou avaient des
origines juives mais les sources sont
incertaines à ce sujet en tout cas elle
est baptisée la vie des milliards et
bien connu grâce à ses lettres sa poésie
ses dossiers judiciaires et le journal
de l'astrologue simon foreman qui
racontent leurs interactions consulter
un astrologue était pour ans à cette
époque
emilia à une soeurs et deux frères qui
n'atteignent pas l'âge adulte
leur père meurt lorsqu'elle n'a que 7
ans et lui laisse une dot 200 livres
qu'elle pourra toucher à son mariage ou
le jour de ses 21 ans après sa mort
emilia être envoyés vivre chez suzanne
berti conteste de kent on ignore si elle
était au service de la comtesse ou sa
pupille
mais cette dernière considère qu'il est
important que les jeunes filles
reçoivent le même niveau d'éducation que
les jeunes hommes
elle reçoit donc une éducation humaniste
et apprend le latin elle vit ensuite
chez marguerite clifford comtesse de
cumberland et sa fille lady anne
clifford en tant que sa tutrice et
compagnie elle y bénéficient d'une
bibliothèque importante et désigne
malgré les fortes dans ses écrits comme
son inspiration et mécène principal
sa mère meurt lorsque miliana que 18 ans
peu de temps après il fait la
connaissance de l'offre enrique carey
cousin de la reine et mécène des arts et
du théâtre
car il ya 45 ans de plus que williams et
devient son amant il lui verse une
pension de 40 livres par an jusqu'à ce
qu'elle tombe enceinte de lui en 1592 à
23 ans pour conserver les apparences car
elle lui offre alors une grosse somme
d'argent el amari à alfonso lasnier
musiciens de la reine et qui se trouve
aussi être le cousin germain d'emilien
son mariage avec alfonso n'est pas
heureux elle s'inquiète du manque
d'avancement de son mari et regrette sa
relation avec reynerie qui est
maintenant décédé et le temps passé à la
cour le journal de foreman son
astrologue raconte n o godman batista
goodship elle a un fils henry issue de
sa liaison est une fille odilia qui
meurent à 10 mois le journal de foreman
suggère qu'elle fait aussi plusieurs
fausses couches
après la mort d' alfonso en 1613 emilia
doit gagner sa vie elle ouvre alors une
école mais elle est arrêtée à deux
reprises à cause de différend sur le
prix de la location des locaux son école
perd en popularité suite à cela on
connaît peu le reste de sa vie
elle engage des poursuites contre le
frère de son mari qui doit lui payer 20
livres on ignore si la somme a été
réellement versés elle passe le reste de
sa vie avec la famille de son fils est
mort le 3 avril n'est ses 145 à 76 ans
si j'ai choisi de vous parler des
milliers à bassano ce n'est pas pour ses
talents relative de directrice d'école
mais pour ses écrits en 1611 a publié un
recueil de poésie salle vd ou srec
studio room elle a alors 45 ans et il
est à cette époque extrêmement rare
qu'une femme anglaise publie ses écrits
seule la religion est un thème jugé
convenable pour les femmes elles peuvent
traduire des textes ou écrire sur leur
expérience religieuse mais guère plus
et avec l'accord de leur mari elle n'est
que la quatrième femme anglaise a publié
de la poésie est la première à tenter
d'en vivre
la diffusion de son recueil pouvant lui
permettre de trouver des mécènes
chaque poème est dédié à une femme
différente de la reine consort aux
femmes qu'elle a connus comme margaret
clifford
il était courant pour les auteurs peu
fortunés ou peu connus d'attirer
l'attention de mes scènes de cette
manière en leur dédiant tel ou tel poème
voire même en vantant leurs vertus dans
leur texte
cependant ce regroupement de femmes est
inhabituel voire unique pour l'époque
jamais auparavant un livre n'avait été
dédiée cas des femmes dans ses écrits
elle s'inspire d'auteurs anciens et de
livres de veronica franco et christine
de pisan dont j'ai déjà parlé dans une
vidéo
son poème titre raconte l'histoire de la
passion du christ de façon satirique est
presque exclusivement du point de vue
des femmes qui l'entourent ce qui est
inédit pour l'époque dans d'autres
textes elle s'attaque à la vanité des
hommes et justifie la liberté dans les
femmes devraient pouvoir jouir elle
s'attarde sur khalidya pro coup là la
femme de pilate qui tentent d'intervenir
lors de la crucifixion de jésus elle
défend aussi les femmes qui suivent
jésus jusqu'à sa crucifixion et
s'attaque au péché originel
défendant rêve et considérant qu adam
est aussi coupable quelle son dernier
poème est dédié à marguerittes clifford
et sa fille et décrit leur maison de
campagne
le règne du roi james ou lequel emilie a
écrit n'était pas très sympathiques
envers les femmes surtout envers celle
qui essayait de prendre la parole
publiquement la religion était un thème
jugé convenable pour l'époque mais
l'aspect parodique voire grotesque pour
donner milhas est considéré par
quelqu'un comme radical voire hérétique
d'autres considèrent emilia comme
profondément religieuse ses textes sont
vus de nos jours comme une première
forme de féminisme elle est mis en avant
les femmes considérant que doivent
s'investir dans le monde matériel et
s'élever au même niveau que les hommes
elle est aussi la première à proposer
une contre mémoire de la mémoire
dominante vu cette fois sous le prisme
des femmes qui contribue un peu comme ce
que j'essaie de faire ici
ce qui est ironique c'est qu'emilia
ensuite elle-même été oubliée pendant
plusieurs siècles on connaît peu la
réception globale de ses écrits mais
bien qu'ils soient de qualité il ne la
rende pas riche les procès qu'elle
entreprend par la suite témoigne de son
besoin d'argent
il est probable qu'elle n'ait pas trouvé
de mécènes suite à sa publication et
elle ne tente plus jamais de publier ses
écrits il existe de nos jours 9 copies
de son cv deus dans cinq complète ou
presque emilie aviv et donc à la même
époque
william shakespeare et écrivait il est
donc tout naturel que les théories les
plus farfelues voit le jour à son sujet
la paternité des oeuvres de william
shakespeare est contesté depuis le 19e
siècle est l'une des théories qu'emilia
soit l'autrice des pièces parmi les
arguments avancés on trouve l'emploi des
noms bas sanyo dans le marchand de
venise
emilia dans othello qui le premier
personnage féminin à tenir des propos
féministe dans le théâtre anglais dans
titus andronicus on trouve ensemble les
personnages des milieux et bastian us en
tout on trouve 6 emilia ou des
variations de ce prénom dans les pièces
de shakespeare bien qu'il soit peu
courant pour l'époque et 2 bassano le
nom d'hôtel au serait inspiré du jésuite
gerolamo othello originaire de la ville
de bassano des références à l'italien et
à l'hébreu dans les pièces de
shakespeare sont également pointés du
doigt parce qu'il ne semble pas qu'il
parlait ces longues de plus emilia jouer
du luth de la harpe et du virginale et
s'y connaissait en musique est en femme
et fille de musicien or on retrouve
énormément de thèmes musicaux dont les
pièces de shakespeare bien qu'il n'ait
pas de formation musicale avait
enfin emilia à la maîtresse de henry
carey qui durant les deux dernières
années de leur relation dirige la
compagnie de théâtre qui joue les pièces
de shakespeare
emilia n'est cependant qu'une des douze
prétendants à la paternité des pièces de
shakespeare sans compter shakespeare
lui-même quand même n'étant pas très
portés sur les complots je ne
m'attarderai pas plus sur cette théorie
une autre idée voudrait qu'emilia et
était une collaboratrice de shakespeare
ou qu'elle soit sa fameuse dark lady la
dark lady de shakespeare est une femme
qui apparaît dans ces sonnets maîtresse
ou femme qui l'aurait éconduit
elle est décrite comme une femme sombre
de cheveux et de pau emilia est décrite
comme dark dans l'une des seules
description dell fait par un cousin
ce qui signifie pour l'époque qu'elle
avait les cheveux noir ou brun ou un air
méditerranéen ce qui est logique vu ses
origines italiennes
il est donc possible que les nombreux
indices qui font penser à certains
qu'emilia a écrit les pièces de
shakespeare sont en fait des dédicaces à
une femme qu'il connaissait
qui sait cette thèse est également
controversée car au manque de preuves
sur l'identité de cette d'arc les i on
ignore si elles étaient d'origine
méditerranéenne ou africaine il existe
au moins cinq autres candidates
potentielles à ce titre et elle pourrait
même tout à fait être une invention de
shakespeare
moi je sais que c'est martin johnson
mais chut
quoi qu'il en soit la juxtaposition de
carrière d'emilia lasnier et de
shakespeare met en évidence le contexte
socio économique et culturel de l'époque
qui crée de nettes différences entre les
carrières des poètes et des poétesses
des différences qu'on retrouve dans sa
mémoire aussi comme le disent marianne
pierre chez valérie smith ce dont une
culture se souvient est ce qu elle
choisi d'oublier sont intimement liés
aux questions de pouvoir et d'hégémonie
et donc aux gens la mémoire des milliers
d'années s'est perdu au fil des siècles
et elle n'est réétudier que depuis ces
dernières décennies grâce au mouvement
des gender studies et grâce aux théories
farfelues sur le lien entre hal et
shakespeare c'est la fin de cet épisode
j'espère que ce nouveau portrait de
femme bien badass vous a plu et à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures de
buck
photo jean marc orgogozo voir vertueuse
ladies and gentlemen of the kingdom come
on dit chez nous sommes partis que la
personne du rhône sexe search for the
most par aso were not myself and stars
idol de teck fingers notre corps annie
better and decided to make no to the
world
tata au women's heures notre bible and
songs for getting by windham size and
enjoy the weekend end de mars